[Music]
hello family I'm Jill morone we welcome
you to 3abn today Bible Q Anda that's
right this is our program where we get
to answer your Bible questions I love
this program because anytime you and I
open up the word of God what happens our
minds and understandings are enlightened
by the power of the holy spirit because
all scripture is given by inspiration of
God we're told that in 2 Timothy chapter
3 and today we're going to open up the
word of God and study together if you
would like to submit a question on an
upcoming Bible Q&A program that we would
love to answer you can send your
questions one of three ways you can send
us an email at bible QA 3abn.org
3975 that's 618 228
3975 or you can go to Instagram and you
can go to 3abn uncore official that's 3
abn's Instagram handle and you can send
your questions that way we would love to
feature them on an upcoming Bible QA
program I'm here today with the Brethren
want to introduce to you my brothers in
Jesus your brothers at home as well we
start at the end Professor Daniel
parents so glad you're here Daniel thank
you it is so good to be here and I'm
just I'm excited for this program comes
out every week because it encourages
people who watch to to then be able to
take Bible answers to those around them
because there's people all around us who
are wanting to know what God's word says
amen we can study and they can share
that's beautiful coming around the table
here Pastor John deny so glad you're
here Pastor it's a blessing to be here
and we are grateful for the question he
gives us an opportunity to dig into
God's word and it's always a blessing
amen last but not least coming around
the table here Ian vandervalk and we're
so glad you're here as well brother
thank you for having me it's always a
pleasure to be on Bible Q&A because I
get excited to hear some of the answers
that they're delivering because I want
to know them too so it's it's a real
blessing amen before we jump into our
first question we want to go to the Lord
in prayer before we open up the word of
God Pastor Johnny would you pray for us
sure our loving Heavenly Father we thank
you so much for the holy scriptures we
thank you Lord that as we look at the
scriptures study them we see that
there's Harmony we see that there's a
message of hope for us and we thank you
because you let us know that we need
your Holy Spirit to understand them and
so we ask for your Holy Spirit now bless
us as we share and we pray that in all
things your name is honored and
glorified in Jesus holy and blessed name
amen amen amen thank you so much our
first question let's go to Professor
parin Daniel this came from Joshua who
lives in South Dakota and he sent it in
via text message with a recent release
of the UFO footage along with
whistleblower testimony to Congress what
could be some biblical explanations for
the UFO and ET phenomenon is it demonic
Angelic Nephilim what would you say well
Joshua this is a good question that a
lot of people ask what's going on up
there the skies in the heavens and first
of all I want to say the most important
thing to keep your eyes on in the
heavens is what Jesus is doing in the
Heavenly Sanctuary which transfers and
translates into a work in our own lives
but UFO for those of you who don't know
unidentified flying object UAP
unidentified anomalous phenomena the
first uh first illust or explanation
from the Bible is not flashy if it's
unidentified it may just mean that you
don't know what it is because sometimes
just because we see something we don't
understand understand doesn't mean it's
out of context it just means we don't
have enough information so there's a
little bit of that going on out there
but sometimes there's something that uh
you don't identify that may not be of
Earthly origin is that a possibility
well if it's not of Earthly origin then
it's extraterrestrial ET
extraterrestrial just means coming from
outside of Earth I got to tell you there
are things outside of this earth like
Angels God's angels don't need to work
by doing some strange lights in the sky
that's not the way God works
but could Satan's Angels do things in
the sky that are are unidentified that
we don't recognize sure that's within
their power but how how the work of
Satan's Angels coordinates with UFOs
it's outside of the explanations of
scripture and we're honestly not invited
to spend lots and lots of time trying to
figure out or or build speculating
theologies off of UFOs and what they
might be but this here is important this
is the time right now of the spreading
of the Three Angels messages to Every
Nation tribe language and people those
three Angels pictured as flying in the
midst of heaven and so UFOs then they're
a diversion they're a distraction the
enemy would love to have us Focus all
our attention and energy and mental
thought process on these unidentified
sites these uh unexpected sites uh to
the exclusion of the expected sites and
what are those expected sites we should
be focusing on and that is people who
want to receive who are ready to receive
the advant aned light of the Gospel that
we have to share and so instead Satan
would love for us to Center our
attention on all these phenomena and we
begin to hyperfocus over here on this
when the real issue that God wants to be
focusing on is over here and so this
hyperfocus on human intelligence I got
to figure out everything that I don't
understand and know because we don't
like to be ignorant all right and
sometimes there are things that we just
need to settle to be ignorant on and so
if we attempt uh to make UFOs our life
study and we buy all the books and we
watch all the videos and we familiarize
yourselves with all those theories we
want to make sure that we understand it
all we might be short changing the types
of things that God wants us to be
studying and knowing everything there is
to know about also I have to point out
this Satan wants our worship what is
that that's our attention that's our
desire that's our longing and he wants
us to be engrossed and en enthralled
with him and so these UFOs then they
become some kind of mystery that leads
people to be engrossed and enthralled
with what is this thing I've got all my
desire and attention fixated on it what
is that and we start to speculate on
what could these intelligent beings be
and and then we start to open ourselves
up to this longing and people have
expressed that if you've watched certain
people's testimony and say I'm ready for
whatever those things are to give myself
fully to them and so they will welcome
their arrival so if there are spiritual
forces behind UFOs there are people
ready to give themselves over to those
things so I just want to counsel you
with this be consumed not with UFOs but
be consumed with Jesus turn all your
attention on the light the identified
the expected light that comes from him
first and foremost and so I haven't
answered all the questions about UFOs I
certainly can't but I have said stay
firmly focused on Jes Jesus and don't
get caught up in UFO Mania get caught up
in Jesus amen thank you so much Daniel
what a great answer there's things
confusing that sometimes are out there
and we need to focus on the word of God
speaking of confusion we're coming to a
question that came in this question is
for Pastor John deny from Tony in Canada
and it came in via text message as well
this has to do with confusion over a
Biblical verse can you please explain
Matthew 222 for I know I'm missing
something in this verse because I
understand that the dead know nothing
and have to wait for the resurrection
when Jesus returns yet this verse is
telling me to raise up a child of one
who is dead of that person's Offspring
so what can you un you can you clarify
the confusion that they're having by the
grace of the lord we will make an
attempt and so i' like to go ahead and
begin at Matthew 22 uh verse 23 and then
include verse 24 the same day came to
him the Sadducees which say there is no
Resurrection resurrection and asked him
saying Master Moses said if a man die
having no children his brother shall
marry his wife and raise up seed unto
his brother so this is the text that
you're talking about and so it seems
like there is a misunderstanding on on
the way you read this verse or
understand this verse this is not
talking about raising a child that is
dead and and and bringing him back to
life this is really talking about that
if a if if your brother dies and there
were there were no children your
responsibility is to marry your
brother's wife and then have children
children through her and raise that
child knowing god serving God and that's
really what is being discussed here and
so you have to uh raise them in the
nurture and admonition of the Lord and
so I read Ephesians chap 6 verse 4 and
it says and ye fathers provoke not your
children to wrath but bring them up that
is raise them up in the nurture and
admonition of the Lord so it is not
talking about raising a child that is
dead but raising them in the knowledge
of God and the things of life not
talking about raising somebody from the
dead thank you so much Pastor Johnny
appreciate that very much um
good Clarity there I do want to add one
more me uh John chapter 5 this is one of
the key verses in John chapter 5 Jesus
makes a statement concerning the people
that are dead notice it says in verse
28- 29 do not Marvel at this for the
hour is coming in which all who are in
the graves will hear his voice and come
forth those who have done good to the
resurrection of life and those who have
done evil to the resurrection
resurrection of condemnation there there
are two resurrections when Jesus returns
for the second time he will raise the
righteous that are dead and then those
that are wicked they are raised at the
end of 1,000 years read Revelation
chapter 20 amen thank you so much thank
you for the opportunity we're going to
Ian now for the next question um this
has to do with some Resurrection or
going straight to heaven um this text
came in how did Enoch or Elijah enter
Heaven before Jesus and the Saints all
right well thank you so much for that
text message uh I'm going to give you
the answer right from the beginning and
then I'll just allow the Bible to
explain itself uh now Jesus did not
enter Heaven after Enoch or Elijah
because Jesus had already been
pre-existent he had already been there
in heaven and I'm going to again allow
the Bible to explain itself so we're
going to look at some very well-known
Bible verses and if this is new to you
these Bible verses just listen closely
uh we're going to start in John chap 1
and we're going to read verses 1-3 and
then we're going to jump down to 4
now starting in John 1:1 it says in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God he was in
the beginning with God all things were
made through him and without him nothing
was made that was made and now in verse
14 and the word became flesh and dwelt
Among Us Now John is none other speaking
than about Jesus here we can see that in
some of his other writings here when he
refers to the word you could see in
Revelation chapter 19 or Revelation 19:
13 where it says he was clothed with a
robe dipped in Blood and his name is
called the word of God so what I like to
do at least for me in this Bible in
these set of Bible verses especially in
John 1 through3 is I like to replace the
word with Jesus it just kind of helps me
understand more of what the texts are
saying so would read like this in the
beginning was Jesus and Jesus was with
God and Jesus was God Jesus was in the
beginning with God and all things were
made through Jesus and without Jesus
nothing was made that was made and so
this is establishing that Jesus has
already been there from the beginning
and we can see it again in John's
writings in John chapter 17 and verse 5
which says oh now oh Father glorify me
together with yourself with the glory
which I had with you before the world
was so this is even establishing that
Jesus has been there even before the
creation of the world uh Paul confirms
this again in Colossians 1 and we're
going to read verses 14- 16 which says
in whom we have Redemption through his
blood obviously that's Jesus the
Forgiveness of sins he is the image of
the invisible God the firstborn over all
creation for by him all things were
created that are in heaven and that are
on earth visible and invisible whether
Thrones or dominions or principalities
or powers all things were created
through him and for him so all of these
Bible verses are really just to
establish all of God's word is to
establish that Jesus was there with God
from the beginning Jesus was there when
the Earth was created Jesus was there at
the creation of man Jesus was in heaven
before Enoch and Elijah Jesus he is the
Alpha and the Omega the beginning and
the end the first and the last and you
can read that in revelation 22 ver vers
13 so just to reiterate Jesus did not
enter Heaven uh after Enoch or Elijah
because Jesus had been there since the
very beginning amen super clear thank
you so much Ian grateful Jesus is
eternal and God and pre-existent we're
going to stay on this concept of the
godhead and move to the Holy Spirit
Pastor John deny we're coming to you
this is from rockan um who lives in
Georgia she sent in this email John
20:22 says when he had said this he
breathed on them and said unto them
receive ye the Holy Ghost how is it that
Jesus breathed the Holy Spirit on the
disciples since the holy spirit is an
individual person thank you very much
this is a good question and let's go
ahead uh and read John chap 15 verse 26
notice what Jesus says here but when the
helper comes whom I shall send to you
from the Father the spirit of Truth who
proceeds from the father he will testify
of me notice that it says here that
Jesus will send the holy spirit in
breathing upon them the Holy Spirit
Jesus is not doing a physical literal uh
breathing of the Holy Spirit into them
this is a symbolic act it symbolizes
represents represents that Jesus is the
one that gives them the Holy Spirit
sends the Holy Spirit uh you can see
examples of prophets doing some
representation of what is going to
happen for example in Jeremiah you see
uh this type of thing where uh they are
said to uh do something to symbolize to
the people of Israel something that's
going to happen to them and uh for
example you have some uh the Lord says
to the prophet go and see the Potter and
uh he sees the Potter making the vessel
and it falls apart and so there are
examples in the Bible of the Prophet
acting something out and when you look
at Ezekiel also he is told lie on your
right side then lie on your left side
and it's a symbol of something that's
going to happen to the people of Israel
so in Jesus doing this breathing upon
them the holy spirit is not the physical
body going out of his mouth and Bre
coming unto the disciples it is a
representation of the Holy SP Spirit
coming from Jesus to them amen
absolutely I like that um let's go to
Daniel here and this goes to jesus'
disciples this came from Janice who
lives in the Philippines and she sent
this by a email what do we know about
Nathaniel aside from his Encounter With
Jesus in John chapter 1 I realized he
was not one of the 12 apostles in Mark 3
and acts 1 I thought he was because of
historian John 1 or was he maybe he's
one of the 70s so what's the identity of
Nathaniel okay Nathaniel is indeed one
of the 12 disciples he's only mentioned
though in the Book of John and just in
two chapters there in John 1 and John 21
but let me let me start by saying in the
Bible there are multiple people both in
the Old Testament and the New Testament
who are referred to by more than one
name and we see that in Jesus disciples
as well there is Simon also called Peter
and then there was Matthew Who is the
same as Levi and you can find those
names in Mark 2:14 and Matthew
9:9 and so that sets a precedent that we
ought to look for uh perhaps with some
other disciples so who John calls
Nathaniel the rest of the three gospels
Matthew Mark and Luke they refer to as
Bartholomew and so Nathaniel Bartholomew
apparently are the same person when John
introduces Nathaniel in chapter 1 veres
45 to 4 49 it is uh Phillip who is
closely associated with him Philips
Philip comes to Nathaniel and says I I
found him that the prophets have spoken
about uh when Luke 6 verse4 and all the
other three gospels the other of the
three gospels as well when they list the
disciples Phillip is paired with
Bartholomew so Philip and Nathaniel and
John Philip and Bartholomew in the other
three gospels John chapter 21 verse 1
and 2 lists some of Jesus disciples and
Nathaniel is included in that list let
me read it to you after these things
Jesus showed himself again to the
disciples at the Sea of tiberias and in
this way he showed himself all right so
these are his disciples Simon Peter
Thomas called the twin Nathaniel of
canaa in Galilee the sons of Zebedee and
two other of his disciples were together
and so Nathaniel is included right there
and this lets us know that Nathaniel was
one of Jesus's 12 disciples and not some
other outside character uh Nathaniel
appears to be his personal name which
means gift of God Bartholomew on the
other hand appears to be a family name
bar means son and tmu refers to Tomi
some people wonder whether or not that's
a reference to the Tomi in first Samuel
in 2 Samuel or 1 Chronicles who is
called the king of gure we don't know
that but if it's true if it's possibly
true then Nathaniel would be one of the
disciples who potentially had foreign
Royal Blood somewhere in in his
line Matthew 10:3 has a similar
description of two disciples that
references both their personal name and
a family name so Matthew 10:3 refers to
James the son of alfus so you got the
personal name James son of alfus part of
his family name and then it refers to
and leus whose surname was thus lebius
personal name thus surname and so in a
Multicultural Society there might be
different reasons for referring to
different parts of a person's name and
John uses Nathaniel personal name
instead of Bartholomew and it gives us a
little bit more insight into his into
who he was but his full name personal
and family name would have been
Nathaniel Bartholomew or Nathaniel son
of Tomi thank you so much Daniel you
know what's fascinating to me is when
you read the Bible as a whole you pull
the different gospels and everything
together you look at it together and
what the word of God has to share and
there's so much more insight to be
gained if you have Bible questions for
us just want to encourage you to send us
an email you can go to Bible QA 3abn.org
that way we would love to take your
Bible questions on an upcoming Bible QA
program let's go to Ian here and this
came in via email from Mark does God
permit murder in the Bible Samson asked
God for strength and God gave him
strength and Samson killed the
Philistines another example is David
asking God for strength and God gave him
the strength to slay
Goliath you know thank you Mark for your
question because this was something
early on in my Christian I also asked
myself because you know how can a god
when we read these stories allow these
things to happen but let me explain
something to you mark death was never in
God's original plan we read in Genesis
1: 27 it says so God created man in his
own image in the image of God he created
a male and female he created them so we
were created in the image of God and the
only reason that we have to experience
you know sickness or disease or old age
or in this case you know with your
question murder
is only because of sin and we're told in
God's word that the wages of sin is
death in Romans 6:23 but let me Define
your question so what you're asking is
does God permit murder so in other words
does God allow or authorize the unlawful
or premeditated killing of another
simple answer is no God does not
authorize the unlawful and premeditated
killing of another so what do we do when
God gives us his commandment and says in
Exodus 20: 13 that says says Thou shalt
not kill or in the new King James it
says murder now this is taken in the
context of unrighteous Vengeance or a
killing for personal gain right so based
on your question on the surface there
appears to be some kind of contradiction
right because on one hand we're told in
Exodus 20 thou shalt not kill but then
on the other hand we see examples of
what has occurred like you suggested in
David and Samson but let me show you the
character of God just for a moment
because we know that God is love right
we see that in 1 John 48 but let me also
use Deuteronomy
32:4 which says he is the rock his work
is perfect for all his ways are Justice
a god of Truth and without Injustice
righteous and upright is he so as
Christians we we must have faith and
trust in God as he executes judgment on
those who seek to destroy his people and
we don't always know why certain things
happen right so in Isaiah 55:9 it says
for as the are higher than the earth so
are my ways higher than your ways and my
thoughts uh than your thoughts so we
have to place our trust in God that he
knows what he is doing so when God or
why does God then command his people
then to destroy their enemies we read in
Deuteronomy 20 and verse 17 and 18 which
says but you shall utterly destroy them
the hittite and the Amorite and the
Canaanite and the perizzite and the
hivite and the jebusite just as the Lord
your God has commanded you now here's
the key in verse 18 lest they teach you
to do according to all their
Abominations which they have done for
their gods and you sin against the Lord
your God now what were some of the
practices that these surrounding Nations
took part in well they took part in
ritualistic prostitution uh human and
child sacrifice sexual rituals
mutilation of their bodies and so much
more grotesque things all of which were
done towards their gods so these nations
essentially had to be destroyed uh for
God in order to to save his people from
being influenced and essentially cut off
the virus that would take place within
his people and let me explain something
also to you God does not take pleasure
in their death we read in Ezekiel 33
and: 11 God says to them as I live says
the Lord God I have no pleasure in the
death of the wicked but that the wicked
turn from his way and live so God
doesn't even take pleasure in the death
of others he wants them to turn from
their evil ways to give their lives over
to him and essentially be back in unity
with him as he originally created us God
does not permit Mur permit murder but
let me tell you who does We read in John
chapter 8 and verse 44 you are of your
father the devil and the desires of your
father you want to do he speaking of the
devil was a murderer from the beginning
and does not stand in the truth so in
closing here's something also for all of
us to think about murder just isn't the
Act of Killing murder comes from a place
of hatred as well we read in first John
chapter 3 and 15 whoever hates his
brother is a murderer so be mindful of
that as well thank you so much Ian
that's one of those difficult topics and
yet we see the outworking of the great
controversy that battle between good and
evil Jesus will be victorious in the end
we know that for sure um we're going to
another confusing conundrum this is a
question for Daniel it came in via email
would you kindly share your
understanding of Ezra chapter 10 it is
one of the most puzzling stories to me
all right thank you for the question
here about Ezra chapter 10 and uh one of
the ways we answer any Bible question is
to look at context and so Ezra chapter 9
sets the context and and kind of gives a
framework for understanding what's
happening there the whole book of Ezra
some of the Jews have returned from
Persia to rebuild Jerusalem but among
them are apparently some men who are
drawn to the women of the land who do
not share their faith and so they let
down their guard and they let down their
standard and they allow their carnal
desires to lead to deluding their faith
by intermarriage with these people from
a neighboring neighboring places so this
isn't just about marriage though chapter
9 verse1 says that they have been become
connected to the Abomination
of the Canaanites so through these
marriages they are connecting with false
gods and this is what this is the main
issue at stake here this is so bad that
verse three of chapter N9 says that Ezra
tore his clothes pulled out his hair and
sat astonished and verse six begins his
prayer like this oh my God I am too
ashamed and humiliated to lift my face
to you my God for our iniquities have
risen higher than our heads and our
guilt has grown up to the heavens and
the rest of his prayer then has words
like shame humiliation iniquity guilt
verse 10 forsaking God's
Commandments and this is exactly what
was going on at the time of Noah Jesus
points this out in Matthew 24:38 that
they were marrying and giving in
marriage there's nothing evil about
marriage in and of itself but when
simply based upon our carnal desires
where we are not directed by God then we
start to blend good with evil and this
reveals that that the power of family
associations is really strong and the
marriage decisions that we make can have
a huge influence on tearing apart the
faith that we or other people have had
and so Ezra and the people see this
going on and they see that this is about
to ruin the fragile Remnant that have
returned chapter 10 verse one then says
because of what has happened the people
gathered together and the people wept
bitterly so all of that context explains
what's going on in Ezra chapter 10 the
the the remaining Remnant are doing
their best now to make this wrong right
to cut off the virus so to speak that uh
that Ian just spoke about that these
marriages that are introducing false
gods and idolatry they have to be cut
off and so the end of verse 14 in
chapter 10 shows that even though no
punishment has yet befallen the Jews
there in Israel in Jerusalem they
recognize that the wrath of God is upon
them and this may be true in our lives
too there might be places where nothing
has yet happened but we're blending our
life with the forces of evil in some
part of our life and God invites Us in
fact he says that for you to preserve
your life you have to cut off the the
influence of evil in your life not to
say that we won't associate with people
to share the gospel but to cut off that
influence thank you so much that's so
sobering and challenging for us as
Christians too let's go to Pastor John
deny next this is a question came in
from Andrew who lives in Florida came in
via email can you please help me
understand this commission are we to
believe that Jesus followers have power
to forgive sins in the case of poery
claiming that Peter was the first pope
was from The Book of John where they
misinterpreted Jesus words about Peter
being a rock it was the idea which he
had spoken not his person I understand
that but the following scripture looks
straightforward so one may understand
why POI claims to have the right to
forgive sins they're talking of course
of John 20:23 if you forgive the sins of
any they are forgiven them if you retain
the sins of any they are
retained that's a very good question and
we thank you for sending it we hope you
send some more yes when you look at this
it may sound confusing but we have to
take a look at the Bible as a whole and
how uh this helps us understand what
this is talking about uh you remember
that Jesus talked about how when you
look at when you look at your neighbor
and he has a problem uh like he has a
speck and then you have a beam in your
own eye we begin to see uh that we have
to be careful about this verse and judge
according to what the Bible says in
Matthew chapter 7 verse1 uh judge not
that ye be not judged so we have to be
careful this is not really talking John
20:23 about an individual one person
having the power to forgive sins or to
retain sins this is talking about uh the
church as a whole a body of Believers
one of the members of the church commits
a a sin breaks one of the Ten
Commandments kills somebody steals the
church as a as a body looks at the
situation and
decides uh
upon the evidence and even questioning
the brother or sister sisters can do
that
too and judge the accordingly according
to what the Bible says yes
unfortunately uh so it's as a body no as
not as an
individual uh let's go ahead and go to
John 20:
21-23 and so uh to give a little context
so Jesus said Jesus said to them again
peace to you as the father has sent me I
also send you he's talking to all of
them you cannot take this as I'm just
sending you one individual and when he
has said this he breathe on them breathe
on them and said to them receive ye the
holy spirit so this judging of the
situation is under the guidance of the
Holy Spirit if you forgive the sins of
any they are forgiven them if you retain
the sins of any they are retained so
it's under the guidance of the holy
spirit that this judging of what the
brother or sister has done
with the body of believers they judge
the case uh Luke 6:37 judge not that you
shall not be judged condemn not and you
shall not be condemned forgive and you
will be forgiven now when a situation
comes up and it's a sin is not that the
church as a body says yeah you know he
killed somebody but they always give
good offerings we we better forgive them
uh no you don't that's not the the
criteria for judging the the criteria is
the word of God the Ten Commandments and
the idea of forgiving somebody even
though they're guilty is it would be
doing something wrong they judge
according to God's word let's look at 1
Corinthians chapter 6 verse 1 2 and 3
dare any of you having a matter against
another go to the law before the unjust
and not before the Saints it doesn't say
Saints it says Saints so if your brother
offended you committed a sin against you
that's used stole something from you you
must report this uh do you not know that
the Saints shall judge the world and if
the world shall be judged by you the
Saints are you unworthy to judge the
smallest matter know ye not know ye not
that we shall judge Angels how much more
things that pertain to this life so as a
body of Believers the church has
Authority from Jesus Christ to judge a
situation where a brother or sister has
done a sin and we are to call Sin By Its
Right name not look at the uh person uh
as far oh he he he gives like I I'm
going to use that again oh he gives a
good offering if we you know punish this
person we're going to have we're going
to have problems no judge according to
God's word amen thank you so much Pastor
Johnny I love that there's a big
difference between forgiveness of sins
and making a judgment call on a
situation what's happening in the church
that's good Ian let's come to you this
came in from Florida via text God said
to Moses see I have made you a God to
Pharaoh did God make Moses into three
persons the same word for God was used
to describe Jesus if the holy spirit is
a person in Matthew 1:18 to20 who is the
father of Christ okay so there's uh
several questions that are that are in
here but what I'm going to do uh is
answer one of them that I believe will
bring clarification to all the others
which is uh simply when the Bible says
that that God uh made Moses as a God to
Pharaoh that's what I'm going to explain
for you um so now you have the text that
you are referencing actually comes from
Exodus 7 and verse one which says and
the Lord said unto Moses see I have made
thee a God to pharaoh and Aaron thy
brother shall be thy prophet and in
verse two it says and you shall speak
all that I command you and Aaron your
brother shall tell pharaoh to send the
children of Israel out of his hand so
what I'd like to what I'd like to do is
just kind of give you a little bit of
context leading up to this on what has
taken place now Moses met God on Mount
Horeb at the burning bush and God was
essentially telling Moses that he wants
to use him to speak to pharaoh to free
his people from Egypt from their
oppression and Moses was feeling
completely inadequate he was giving God
all sorts of reasons hey I think you got
the wrong guy I can't speak well uh this
isn't really the task that I should be
doing there's got to be somebody else
who can do it well after some back and
forth with God and Moses finally uh
Aaron shows up in the scene and he says
look here's your brother and I'm going
to have Aaron speak for you now in
Exodus 4: 16 it says and this is
speaking between Moses and Aaron so he
shall be your spokesman to the people
and he himself shall be as a mouth for
you and you shall be to him as God so
we're seeing that same kind of phrase
here as well so what's one of the ways
that God speaks to his people he does it
through His prophets just as God would
give a message to his prophet and then
that Prophet would deliver the message
to the people that it's intended to the
same was happening here between Moses
and Aaron Moses would give Aaron the
message and Aaron would then transfer
that message to who it would needed to
be delivered to now Moses in a
figurative sense was acting as God um
giving the message to Aaron now we know
again that uh God would speak through
His prophets we see this confirmed also
in Hebrews chapter 1 and verse one where
it says God who at various times and in
various ways spoke in time pass to the
fathers by the prophets so now we're
going to readdress the question that you
asked which comes from Exodus 7 and
verse1 that says see I have made thee a
God to Pharaoh now Pharaoh was by far
superior to Moses in every worldly sense
uh Moses was a shepherd and Pharaoh was
well a pharaoh that was the title that
was given to an Egyptian king so the
Pharaoh was a ruler he was wealthy he
had command over people uh over armies
and Moses was essentially a nobody uh in
the eyes of man but what can God do with
somebody who just appears to be common
now Moses was given Authority and had
access to divine power through God and
essentially Moses was acting as God
performing these Miracles through the
plagues and everything else that took
place so now we know that he could not
do these things as mere man uh these
things that he was doing was only by
divine power only given to him by God uh
so God didn't turn Moses into three
beings or in a in a sense of a of the
godhead um basically what he was doing
is he was just simply an instrument that
was used by God to act as a Heavenly
representative in the eyes of pharaoh
amen thank you so much Ian great answer
God used Moses in that situation I love
that uh Daniel let's come to you I think
this is your last question here this
came from South Africa via email Marisa
what does the Bible say about
intermarriage between the races there
are many races in the world Native
Americans Koreans black Caucasian
European the list could go on did God
create these groups of races for a
reason and would he have a concern if
they were mixed so what about
intermarriage between races okay this
question if you've been pay attention
and following through this hour is kind
of connected to the last one I answered
about what happened in Ezra chapter 10
the Human family is one family all
genetically united through the original
DNA that God implanted and created in
Adam and Eve all that genetic diversity
of the entire Human family descends from
those two strands of DNA that God put in
Adam and put in Eve we are one family
yes One race the human race that's what
we are so what we call races are genetic
similarities that we that we recognize
that have developed over time because of
geographic
isolation what happened was back in
Genesis 11 God confused the languages of
the people of the Power Tower of Babel
and based upon the a unified language
that God created uh the people separated
and moved to different places in
different directions and that geographic
isolation then led to certain features
becoming more prominently expressed uh
in in the different groups of people as
they traveled in different places and so
these common physical features reveal
the genetic diversity that God already
had created in Adam and Eve but we're
still one large family uh the Human
family the human race the separation
that God made was not into races but
into languages the language groups are
what God created now the Bible actually
has several examples of people marrying
someone who did not come from the same
family line a couple of those examples
are Moses and Zapora all right then
another one is Boaz and Ruth they came
from different families from Moab and
from Israel but uh spiritually they
actually shared the same Faith
spiritually they were not intermarrying
Boaz and Ruth they had the same faith in
the same God remember that Ruth says to
Naomi your God shall be my God what God
forbids is not intermarriage because you
have different physical features but as
intermarriage with those who do not
share your faith in God biblical faith
in God because that weakens our
conviction it dilutes our influence in
our family and our influence elsewhere
so physically intermarriage is fine with
someone who with what we would call A
different race because we're really all
the same race what God does forbid is
intermarriage with those who do not
share your faith that would be spiritual
intermarriage in Deuteronomy 7 vers 3
and 4 illustrate this says nor shall you
make marriages with them referring to
the Canaanite people talking to is
Israel you shall not give your daughters
to their sons nor take their daughters
for your sons for they will turn your
sons away from following me to serve
other gods that's the issue at stake
here and that's the kind of
intermarriage that was going on in
Genesis chapter 6 in Ezra chapter 7 and
with Solomon and his many wives
intermarriage wasn't the only issue
having all those wives was also not good
in the New Testament last part here
interracial Mar marriage is not
mentioned at all in any way but 2
Corinthians 6:14 does say do not be
unequally yolked together with
unbelievers so the same message of the
Old Testament find a partner who shares
your faith in God from the Bible and you
can be a unified witness demonstrating
the character of God through your family
to those around you amen good answer
thank you Daniel for that let's come
back to Ian this came from Kelly via
email can you be baptized
outside of the church all right Kelly uh
thank you so much for your email and I'm
going to be completely honest with you I
wasn't entirely sure what you are asking
but I didn't want to just bypass your
question so I'm going to answer this in
the sense of whether you can be baptized
and not have to join a church so we read
in Acts chapter 2 in verse 38 41 and 47
those are the verses that we're going to
look at so acts 2: 3841 and 47 which
reads then Peter said to them repent and
let every one of you be baptized in the
name of Jesus Christ for the remission
of sins and you shall receive the gift
of the Holy Spirit now here's verse 41
then those who gladly received his word
were baptized and that day about 3,000
Souls were added to them now verse 47
praising God and having favor with all
the people and the Lord added to the
church daily those who were being saved
so now I understand that the baptism
that it is a public Declaration of an
inward decision that you want to live
with Christ and yes when you are
baptized you're symbolically putting to
death the old you and Rising into a
newness of life that is in Jesus but
what Peter is saying here is he's not
Peter isn't adding these people to
himself it wasn't Peter saying be
baptized and go on your Merry way in
verse 47 it says and the Lord added to
the church so what's the purpose then of
being baptized if you're going to
completely segregate yourself from other
and from the church we read in 1
Corinthians 12 and we're going to read
in verses 12-4 which says as the body is
one and has many members but all the
members of that one body being many are
one body so also is Christ for by one
Spirit we were all baptized into one
body whether Jews or Greeks whether
slaves or free and and or excuse me and
have all been made to drink into one
spirit for in fact the body is not one
member but many now when you keep
reading these verses all the way through
verse 20 it's basically giving
illustrations about how an ear is not an
eye and an eye is not an ear or a mouth
and it's just giving different um you
know uh illustrations about the body and
how one it may not feel like the other
but all of this to say that each part
plays a significant role in the body
being in in God's church and each person
has a very important part to play in
God's Church everyone has been given a
gift
1 Corinthians 12: uh 28 says and God has
appointed these in the church first
apostles second prophets third teachers
after that Miracles then Gifts of
healing helps administrations varieties
of tongues and then we also see in
Ephesians chapter 4 which is kind of a
parallel uh to 1 Corinthians chapter 12
it says there is one body and one Spirit
just as you were called in one hope of
your calling one Lord One Faith one
baptism and in uh Ephesians chapter 4 it
goes on to say you know God has
appointed some to be Apostles some to be
evangelists and pastors and teachers so
when you get baptized you are also to
join a church because God has given you
a gift to spread the ministry of Jesus
Christ we see that in Ephesians 4:12 the
purpose is for the equipping of the
Saints for the work of ministry and for
the edifying of the body of Christ amen
so what does that mean get involved in
church with your brothers and sisters
that's beautiful Pastor Johnny we're
coming to you this came from Samuel who
lives in Virginia he sent it in via
email does the Bible support the name
change or is it appropriate to call
Daniel Azariah mishel and haniah by
their Pagan
names thank you so much Samuel for that
question and I know it's not my son
because he's not in
Virginia so uh there's not a verse that
says uh we do not support this but we
can look at the Bible and find
principles that help us to understand
this when you look at Exodus 20:3 Thou
shalt have no other gods before me you
have to take that into consideration
that the names that were given to the
Hebrew we call them the Hebrew wories uh
they were given names according to the
gods of Babylon and they say that even
the word Babylon means the Gate of the
gods they had many gods so each one was
given a name according to one of the
Gods of Babylon and when you look at
that uh you would think well this is
displeasing to God now I have to walk
around with the name of a pagan God so
in essence they had no control over that
but uh it it would be displeasing to God
for a Christian to take on a name of a
pagan God it would be displeasing to God
in Exodus
23:13 it says and in all things that I
have said unto you be circumspect and
make no mention of the name of other
gods neither let it be heard out of your
mouth so the idea of you taking a name
of a pagan God it shouldn't even be
coming out of your mouth and have that
type of name I'm sure they were not
happy to have their names change because
they have wonderful names Daniel means
God is my judge haniah Yahweh is
gracious and uh
mishael who belongs to God and as a
Yahweh helps and to say you can't use
these names anymore it was a way of
psychologically uh telling them forget
your God and this is now who you are it
it it's it's a psychological thing uh
but this was a practice among nations
when somebody from another Nation came
look at Joseph when he went into Egypt
his name was changed but he knew who he
was and so the Hebrew word knew who they
were so the I the question you also ask
is it appropriate to call Daniel and
mishael and haniah by their Pagan
names um
we if we were there and we knew their
names I would use the the name Daniel
but notice it's interesting Daniel
continued to be called Daniel by uh as
as we as we read here he continued to be
called Daniel Daniel chapter 6 verse 19
and 20 then the king of rose very early
in the morning and went in haste unto
the den of lions and when he came to the
den he cried with a lamentable voice
unto Daniel and the King spake and said
to Daniel oh
Daniel servant of the Living God is thy
God whom thou service continually able
to deliver thee from the Lions and of
course Daniel answered and also uh in
other places his name Daniel was used
and so yes uh it's not appropriate but
Daniel continued to be called Daniel and
perhaps the others were as well by their
real names that's a good point
absolutely we just have just over a
minute here I'm going to throw a very
quick question give me a few second
answer for your devotional time with God
in the morning what do you like to
study well it's always changing isn't it
good I got to tell you just this morning
I finished Jeremiah chapter 51 so I'm
coming to the end of Jeremiah and when
you get to the end of a book especially
a long one like that what's next I'm not
sure I think I'm going to go to uh
Lamentations and just keep on going
through the Old Testament I love that
Pastor Johnny a few seconds I I just
continue going from one book to another
according to ways in the Bible but I'm
interested in doing the Chronological
Study of the Bible what about you Ann so
I kind of mix things up a little bit so
there's some mornings I I read specific
devotionals and other times I just you
know I allow God to speak to me through
his word and just uh study that too amen
I love that so that means at home get
involved in studying the word of God
study to show yourself approved un God
but study to know Jesus study to
discover who he is and there's many
different varieties of having that time
with Jesus but spend time with him we
want to give you opportunity to share
your Bible question and we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult ult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
we are so glad that you joined us here
for today's 3bn Bible Q&A program we
love studying the word of God together
and with you at home want to give each
one of you an opportunity to share some
closing thoughts Daniel we'll start with
you yeah I thought it was interesting
that I had a couple of questions that
dealt with marriage and I just wanted to
encourage those of you who are going to
get married soon place that decision in
God's hands and say Lord lead me to the
one that you have chosen to be a
blessing in my life that I can be a
blessing and prepare for that experience
of marriage by spending time first with
Jesus day by day amen amen I just want
to encourage people to continue studying
God's word asking for the Holy Spirit to
help you understand it and you will be
blessed amen and this kind of goes along
the line of what my last question was
about the baptism and whether or not if
we get baptized that we have to join a
church and I just want to encourage you
really just to make sure sure that you
get involved this is what Christ has
called us to do with one another to lift
each other up to be there for the
healing of each one another and it even
says in God's word that he has given us
a Ministry of reconciliation we are try
to reconcile others to Christ because
that division has taken place between
God and man and we want to reconcile one
another back to God and that doesn't
just take place in the secular world but
also in the church as well because we
all need healing no matter where we are
in our spiritual walk amen amen thank
you so much Ian and Pastor Johnny and
Daniel thank you for your study of God's
word love hearing what God has given you
to share we thank you for joining us as
well at home um I want to leave you with
this scripture we're in Isaiah 52 verse
S how beautiful upon the mountains are
the feet of him who brings good news
publishes peace and brings Tidings of
Salvation so study the word of God and
then share that GI of Salvation through
Jesus with someone else bye-bye
[Music]